[Música]
hola bienvenidos la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
instagram decidió pausar temporalmente
el lanzamiento de una versión de su
plataforma para niños menores de 13 años
la decisión llega solo días después de
que el periódico estadounidense the wall
street journal revelara documentos
internos de facebook que sugieren que la
compañía reconoce que su famosa
aplicación de fotografías es dañina para
adolescentes la red social dijo que
estos hallazgos son inexactos y que por
el contrario instagram ha sido útil para
los jóvenes empezamos
desde que se anunció el lanzamiento de
la versión de instagram para menores de
13 años se produjo una creciente presión
sobre la compañía para que desistiera de
su proyecto ahora su director adam mazer
y dijo que esta idea no verá la luz al
menos por ahora según sus creadores con
instagram kids los menores tendrían su
propio espacio en línea y así dejarían
de fingir su edad para acceder a la
versión principal de instagram aunque se
dijo que esta aplicación estaría
totalmente controlada por los padres
despertó preocupaciones sobre la
seguridad la privacidad y hasta la salud
mental y emocional de los menores a
pesar de las críticas moser y dijo creer
firmemente que la creación de instagram
kids es lo correcto
vamos a dar un paso atrás y vamos a
tomar este tiempo para hablar y escuchar
a padres expertos en seguridad e
investigadores y tener más consenso
sobre cómo avanzar exactamente pero
también vamos a tomar algo del trabajo
que hicimos para instagram kids
específicamente control parental y
llevarlo a adolescentes más ampliamente
hemos visto a competidores y hacer un
trabajo similar incluso para aquellos
menores de 13 años específicamente
youtube
y hablamos con padres de todo el mundo y
oímos consistentemente que están
buscando nuevas formas de supervisar y
moldear la experiencia que sus hijos
tienen en línea y en redes sociales no
está claro si la decisión de instagram
fue producto de la creciente presión
pero llega justo días después de un
informe del periódico estadounidense the
wall street journal que reveló que
facebook es consciente de que instagram
es dañino para los adolescentes el
diario tuvo acceso a documentos que son
producto de una investigación interna
sobre cómo su aplicación afecta a sus
millones de jóvenes usuarios se
conocieron varias diapositivas de este
estudio en las que por ejemplo se lee
que 1 de cada 5 jóvenes dice que
instagram los hizo sentirse peor acerca
de ellos mismos o que la presión social
especialmente en torno a la imagen
corporal hace que los adolescentes se
sientan mal o los lleva a establecer
estándares poco realistas de ellos
mismos incluso se halló que los
adolescentes que luchan con problemas de
salud mental dijeron que instagram hace
que sea peor
pero facebook emitió un comunicado
cuestionado el informe del wall street
journal y aseguró que es inexacto que su
propia investigación demuestra que
instagram es tóxico para los
adolescentes
la compañía se empeñó en destacar los
aspectos positivos de su estudio e
insistió en que muchos de los
adolescentes entrevistados sintieron que
instagram los ayudó en los momentos
difíciles y así lo resalto antagónico
davis directora de seguridad global de
facebook quien compareció frente al
subcomité de protección al consumidor
del comité del comercio del senado tras
el reporte del wall street journal
work estamos totalmente en desacuerdo
con la forma en que estos informes
caracterizaron nuestro trabajo así que
queremos ser claros con lo que la
investigación muestra y lo que no
muestra la investigación mostró que
muchos adolescentes dijeron que
instagram les estaba ayudando con
problemas difíciles que son tan comunes
en la adolescencia
y
quiero dejar claro que esta
investigación no es una bomba no es una
investigación casual
es una investigación direccional que
usamos en esta investigación es una
bomba es evidencia poderosa apasionante
y fascinante de que facebook conoce los
efectos dañinos de su sitio en los niños
y que ha ocultado estos hechos y
hallazgos pero cuáles son las
preocupaciones concretas sobre el uso de
estas aplicaciones por parte de menores
quién debe tomar acciones para
garantizar su seguridad y sobre todo
cómo hacerlo se lo preguntamos a la
doctora clarisa morón ella es psicóloga
clínica con experiencia en niños
adolescentes y adultos la mayor
preocupación de nosotros como los
terapeutas en cuanto al manejo de redes
sociales con los niños en la online los
niños no tienen aún esa capacidad de
percepción la mano de emocional la
bandeja a nivel mental para poder
discernir de quién me está hablando y
quién me está contactando a través de la
red es una responsabilidad de participar
que tanto de padres como de los
productores las personas que se encargan
de todo este tema del desarrollo de
aplicaciones son lo normal deben estar
presentes con los niños sordos los niños
pequeños a ver qué es lo que están
viendo yo me muevo con mi hijo a ver qué
es lo que ve que después del mensaje que
le están transmitiendo yo después
interpretar ayudarles interpretar y
hacer la reflexión con ellos eso es
prácticamente en eso lo mismo del
adolescente generar un espacio abierto
de comunicación abierta y explicarles
los riesgos de lo que se pueden
encontrar veamos ahora cómo registrar
esta noticia algunos de los principales
medios de comunicación del mundo un
análisis del 'washington post' sugiere
que instagram no es un lugar para niños
el portal de tecnología techcrunch
titula facebook sabe que instagram daña
a los adolescentes ahora su plan de
abrir la aplicación parece peor que
nunca the guardian del reino unido dice
facebook cuestiona su propia
investigación que muestra los efectos
dañinos de instagram en la salud mental
de los adolescentes mientras que la
revista 'time' asegura que instagram
está causando daño grave a nuestra
generación necesitamos ayuda para
detenerla
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
puntos france24 puntocom
[Música]